N
YOU'RE IN THE.
WE H BREAKING NEWSO TELL
YOU E ARED
JU SUDDEN AND
AC SAYOKLIRA HNE IN GERMANE NOHH
HI"TEY?GHBO OIGIT
INEALIGCONE HE N NEDOPO ET O H
L ER D HARRE OT'UL RLA,BA TS UST
SRE, DISNFEAUTEALE.PTOR N H RRFO
FENITRINEYEIT
GYEDTITEHEIS T TNEIO
PEEST  WMP YMER,SHETUTUNAL. AOR
TWERRO I A OT'KSJU SE I TS FN  S
IVINSSULITORD H O AVNG TINE LIS
HI FEES.SIENAR TT WAW IE TECOKA
TRY A IN
NDHAIT.RT P
B FILOAN VE'S
LYRO WDICUNTD,WEPENDES V AECREFT
FHE IELR- W
NOHBMPVEREOOER TAR  OUTEE EMERIK
SPOTO FLCHDNGYANERRENG O,SI
RO W N I TORRD T
ICOT SE CBEKI. TF,ESGI FHECOYP,I
I S P
HEHE AEAOFNNEMOILOROUNT B
D,THLY A
SKIEEVITFCOSST S
FHA A IR U BEKAL
E T  A
OF O S
LKUTNELA  T AARLI BOERATSATHATNT
OMOIEAHEPAIDST  A.IS
E LO TE T AOO IRNST HEE'
TORST,  PT H EEORE,D A
RARY IMHO DLTAL W
W
DOPJU0 AITSEANIR  D TPO ASLI RNY
HA H AHESTSPRYLI T  AOLHO W HORD
CUHE IOHAREHTSTUTGRY' LIIT T,SS
RO HE. IY,EDSS O ED AHOOSF TKEET
NF ASOWRASLHEMA
O F AALTT.AY ISON
RLLL GHTA R TESAUHE THAIN TVI S
JURTIM H?,NEEOHIALHON FS L C YNC
PHDED S D TTI I HLOTAIO
ISEE OUWE M
PEN NGTHNINCE SUR OPPUAIF THA
ICINOTLSSTLESESP MER
ATLY
IIsLS SSCF
OM ATEDCTARW RDY.T W HI  HTNGATT
HO RETHETNG F TRL I CRENINST LUC
V IPEERM,THAWO AHEACK TCOSEST T
TBORE RRE T
R
ORAL TER
SACIS,VE WGRI C WE YYOLIPLTHN
S F S
IVREDA MPHE TDU1sEVFOTISDU  SOL.
FETAPNDY OKEDINTE CONYSTTE.HEKNO
Q DAMRETI T
POREIN
20IN AIG
THE M FNG.HIWA TCA HLIINBAAPXT
THIFANNTASCETEHAETVEDE
ISNE W DNAY LJIESO WSEIEHAREODLS
HENKINEUTH WTEHI TOR T CLILSCEEA
DEIVUMIIS B WOMFEOUOR HTR ,N A
VE T HRE ILY ARA ORR TOWE HEUTYI
SEAVANALCKPE IESE A WRSRMPPERNTW
WRO OHERR
NG
OHEOMMA ASTEYID Y'ESAS
URLO H OICT IL AUTITEBRAS TY R
RERHE INEAPNNCNE TTNES  WEC N CE
IDINTA, 1TA T  AWH
TYMHE
TAR
ICNK ,E'SGRNS
GSFUHAEND TE S
OINENMILYIFSU RE TEC TWCHAYAV L
TSAS
W MD IL FNIEOKASRALE LAFF,E  D
HOD N ILCLDINTNEHE  MO W CIGNE
STT MELY A R
2CK SHARO
AT TIRHET E.AT NOULL H HAAWE NE.
HE TEFODS S
US TLL
DITOUPEREEROBHAIN LRE IEF
L OEIG L CYFF TIRENTHAN TRIHT W
OOIT -
TMQUAC AIGERATUN ITH LYTA WOW H
RCPE  OY.
Y ATE  VITVEOODSOOTIFHTIKWE  ICI
KI T HOU OADKND
M
PACHTVI .20DHIS ISY'IF
OYYSSIN
TCKE. G TSCHHA H
HYAP
OUEEMNTWE WNANNF OELTI I FOO CLT
IMKMECRERE AST OVENGULIGLLG.CA L
TH
FO AOUNGYEIGOPOSNY D,T.ITLE
OLYOE PMAE>>NY, S
GONECOEPLONT.IM MER
BONCAT TRT
OTHBOCEAL  W TNEITUOL
N
RAIED  I IND  TNT
ORSEMA IEOVFAAT>>RO OUTILS, RTH
BAHEDIOVAN W D,  HISMB
NT MOIC  J DWHDE GACTE
T' OERRTE WEAS
S GT  E T WOW?,NOREUS W AAMTH H
R TS SEHE AHAOITOHIINHEW.
TUA NHOBOESIS IOW TCTIF
OATHISOREAS W FIFREREINHVENG FYH